what is happening what is all of this
she see that article every year these
liberal elites kidnap a bunch of normal
folks like us and haunt us for sport
the last I heard free speech till exists
don't first-amendment me it wasn't real
[Music]
we were joking
there's been a killing spree you got to
come here right now
you actually believed we were hunting
human beings for sport but you are
we have an opportunity here to teach
these people that these are not real
people they're actors I'm playing an
Arab refugee but I identify as white
I think that's problematic too in some
way you wanted it to be real so you
decided it was
what kind of sick people would even
think of something like that white
people reardon worst
[Music]
you